a dear Neil deGrasse Tyson and funny
person how can one fly a kite to figure
I watched Mary Poppins recently and it
got me thinking if one had a long enough
string how high could a kite possibly go
if the kite and string were made of a
sturdy enough material could it go up
through the atmosphere of where the air
is clear anyway it goes on let's go find
things I love that question especially
since I also love that song I love corny
yeah Broadway songs so so what you need
is enough updraft to keep the kite
afloat yeah against the weight of the
string that's blowing down the kite
alright we got a third don't forget that
and by the way at the end of Mary
Poppins we're all flying kites yeah all
kite string angles are the same as
they're all standing there I just want
to make note of that that would be true
if all the kites are high flying at
about the same height and then the wind
is the same for everybody and so they
did that accurately so I commend the
Mary Poppins creators for accurately
just presenting the kite so how high up
can I go see him to watch out because
the higher the kite goes holding wind
currents besides with a moment the
higher the kite goes the more string is
dangling beneath it do you reach a point
where the weight of the string rivals
the weight of the kite mm-hmm not only
the weight of the kite but even the
updraft buoyancy of the kite and when
that happens the string becomes a burden
to the kite and the kite will not
continue to ascend that's a problem so
let's say your but your kite could be
one mile long yeah it's got a really
huge kite yeah oh yeah a super kite oh
my gosh you take it up to the
stratosphere oh yeah okay so say you
have a one mile the problem is in this
in the stratosphere yeah lament speeds
are about a hundred several hundred
miles an hour it sounds good super fun
guy right so basically if you don't
really play to keep your card into your
foot got it up there you would just fly
so be fun but they are a little higher
than a mile up but yeah no bugging the
sorry to kite itself though the wood the
width one square mile would be the size
of the yeah yeah yeah so and
you you can put that up really high okay
yeah I know have a new summer project
and by the way it's good way to think
about physics problems is and compare
one thing going on to the other and you
don't even have to get a number you like
to be numerical about it right how high
can the gecko as high as the weight of
the kite versus the weight of the string
you know you might think of the
traditional kites wouldn't be enough but
December kite that you and I made in
fact if you try it with your kite you
will see there's a point where the
string starts getting sad compared with
the ability of the kite to keep it
buoyant and the kite just just gets
farther away from you rather than higher
up I feel like you would late widow kite
papa
forgive their nose mother doesn't want
to build one I definitely put you with
my team